Anglin does not look so different from
Scotland they are sisters
Queen Elizabeth your cousin Mary has
returned to take up her throne in
Scotland the Queen
my dear cousin Elizabeth I hope we might
meet in person because I might embrace
you but ruling side-by-side we must do
so in harmony not through a treaty
drafted by men lesser than ourselves my
dear cousin that power nations cherish
each other as we would two kingdoms
United how did the world come to this
quais main servicing the whims of women
Mary is our phone we must never bound to
her as we bow before you
you have the boldness to doubt my
judgment she is only your queen if I
should not produce enough why does he
play do you have a man booth
[Music]
with heavens blessings we bring an heir
to Scotland and to England
it is a clear provocation when you must
make war in Scotland oh so put your
skills to use
do not play into their hands our hatred
is precisely what they hope for I know
your heart has more within it than the
men who can't kill you you would do well
to watch your work I will not be scolded
by my inferior your area
are you afraid Henry no good because our
swords are not just for sure
we have a scourge upon our land
there's a woman with a crowd
Beauty bravery now I see there's no
cause Fendi
your gifts will be your downfall
should you murder me remember you murder
your sister and you murder your queen
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you